I think he's likable by default yeah he
just has a Charisma yeah he's got the
res as everyone says oh I think he just
he just carries a thing where you're
like are we talking about cool Anthony
regular Anthony yeah
[Music]
welcome back everyone to another amazing
episode of careful boys today we have
Bart Nick Colleen Joe Steve and myself
everybody has to answer this I don't
care how you feel about it okay ready
what do you believe
makes you likeable I don't care if you
like me that's what makes me like them
all hey I like that I think that that's
it I really don't care
what if I cared so much about what
people thought of me I don't even think
I'd be on the tubes for as long who
helped you get to that my um was your
mentors yeah my mentor Trenton yeah
damn he really did Supply you with the
good big time Big Time I got lucky yeah
that's a hard thing to I think come to
like it's hard to arrive to the point of
like you know what I really don't care
well you can let people uh Drown Your
Voice out with what they think right and
and I hope that people listen to me on
this if you're especially if you're new
and you're making you're trying to make
stuff for yourself one of the biggest
Follies that people fall into they're
making something and they have a small
audience and they really do care about
their audience I know they do and
they're like hey give me feedback and
then the feedback becomes the content
mistake that's not your content anymore
you're just letting other people Wag the
Dog there's no longevity in that too
because how long can you keep that up
you can't you're making you're trying to
please other people so then eventually
they'll turn against you you're not
innovating you're just people pleasing
that's it wow it's not a way to make
it's called pandering yep
huge mistake but yeah I've only ever
survived in any in any of this [__] by
not worrying about if people like me or
not because I don't care I do like it
when people like me obviously I'm a
human being but I don't you're not
disappointed you know someone's like Ah
that's Steve green guy Mama I'm like
yeah good uh I I don't like a lot of
people too like you know what I mean
for damn sure yeah what about you man
that's a tough question dude uh they're
really tough because I never thought
about that yeah like why do people like
you or what just what do you believe
yeah what do you do what do you think
why people like you oh because I'm
entertaining as [__] [__] hell yeah
extremely
I say intrusive thoughts I do things
that
people probably keep in the in their own
mind when it's all true and I'm like
laughing at the facade of what we call
reality and then they think that's funny
because they're afraid to say that
because of social like
I don't know like it's not it's not
correct it's it's socially incorrect
right so then but then after disruptor
he's also a non-sequitur user I think
that makes you hella likable a what a
non-sequitur user a sequitur
non-sequitur what's that you'll just be
like I like to watch dinosaurs fighting
in my head
I mean who doesn't and people are like
I've never heard that before and it has
nothing to do with relevant relevance of
the conversation they're like but I like
it or the article and I'm laughing I
think when I realized that
people care more about themselves than I
care about what they think of me I that
was so liberating because then when I
was in class and I was like like a kid
like I was about to read the story and I
didn't practice and I was just like [__]
I'm just like so scared
and then I looked around and everyone's
practicing Their Own Line in their head
and when you're doing the speech
everyone's just worried about them doing
their speech right and then Saul's like
why do I care if they don't care
then why does it matter and then and
then if you make someone feel not on
like if you don't judge them because
there are a lot of people that are judgy
as [__] right then they they feel
relaxed around you and I think that's
that's the key is p if people feel like
you accept them and and and they feel
relaxed around you and not judged that's
it's so simple they love you after that
I love them yeah that is cool I think
there's like two versions of the
question like one what you think and
then going around the room and everybody
thinking or saying what they think about
you oh yeah that's nice like the
internal reception and then the outside
perception
so I like
I like to share anything
because Jiu Jitsu good technique we
should start with what he thinks and
then we can tell so you go first what do
you think uh because think about you
have friends and then people on on uh uh
people that are fans of JK they
instantly liked you why do you think
that is don't [__] Dodge the question
you answer it you [__] I always
feel like especially recently I I try I
really do try to take uh because into
consideration what you guys always say
about me deflecting and I really try not
to deflect and I really try to answer
the question wholeheartedly so my
question is my answer to the question is
Barb do you want to go no I'm sure
is is uh I I think I just don't take
myself that seriously
yeah yeah I guess that's great people
people need to I don't know you're like
the anti-bragger right he talks so low
of himself that nobody wants to get his
business
[Laughter]
that is absolutely true he's a he's a
he's a he's a trainer and everyone's
like I'm not gonna learn from you then
yeah you can't even tell people well we
throw them on grinder for 10 seconds
he's 100 you guys want to [__] them so
what does that say to be fair I think I
think if we throw you guys on Grindr you
guys will get the same if you could um
like if Yelp asked you to rate your own
business because they just needed
something would you give yourself five
stars yeah I think I do a good job what
do I do
yeah
that's dope wow you know what a lot of
people think so Ryan had to destroy his
phone because so many grinder things he
deleted the grinder app and he was still
getting notifications
he had to put his phone in the toilet
and flush it yeah yeah I just [__] on it
you got to figure out your push
notifications or something I don't know
what it is
first of all is there anything likable
about you
no
that's what's so likable are you so
honest like what's likable I think maybe
because I like the goof around
he's a goof the guy he's a goof he's a
goofy guy we all voted no on that we all
voted like to [__] around a lot and I
I'm usually I retract my statement it's
hard to I think like for me to be in a
bad mood
maybe that's why because you have no
emotions because you don't
you don't deserve to be in a bad mood
right yeah yeah yeah I'm being an idiot
if I'm in a bad mood yeah so he has
forced fun yeah
that's cool it's also what we portray
bro these are weird
because it's also what we I think
there's also another layer to it right
it's like the people who really know us
in real life and why they like us and
then we're also entertainers so why do
they like us for that aspect the layers
the layers right well for you it's
obvious right you're a [__] fantastic
father
like unbelievable father like you care
more than anybody about being a dad I
see Jill doing everything and Bart just
like nothing
and Mark nothing at all
I'm more into anything than his kid yeah
like no that's true he loves being a
family man you won't shut up about Taiko
dude he's like oh shut up then
well now you're not likable yeah now we
hate you all but no that is something
that I've noticed about you knowing you
pre type of post haika like you just
like all of a sudden became like Dad
mode guy and like it's an it's really
awesome to see oh thank you yeah I love
it thank you yeah I think it's cool to
see you I think once you decide to do
something you put all your resources and
effort into it and I think that's really
cool that's likable to me it's not like
oh that guy's a [__] well no but
you're not a pain in the ass about it
like you will actually downplay it yeah
so we're like man that's cool Bart
you're doing lifting thing next one he's
like yeah but it's [__] whack it
sucks
would you do it all the way in a fledge
and you just like keep it to yourself
you know but that's cool unless we have
to pry it open out of you you know but
like it's cool to see you go in that
mode to me at least say you know what I
realized I have a lot of autistic
friends that are close yeah first one of
them right I'm one of them and then I
realized that you need to have one
though you gotta have yeah the reason
why is because most folks with autism
are just straight up like there's
nothing
like no filter no and I and I appreciate
that like it's it's just even if it
might be socially unacceptable like it's
just clear and it's like with great
intentions and it's just easy yeah
there's no
like you know this ulterior motive or
there's no like person that's like I
thought you were my friend but really
you're my friend of me or you're
competing against me or no snake snaking
yes yeah and actually snaking and the
weird gray area of friendship that's
actually normal out there that's why I
was like oh that's why all of my friends
are retards because they're straight up
they're completely honest whereas like
like have you seen have you been in I
just been in other friend groups like
these days because like like I I've been
hanging out with you guys mostly but now
like I'm meeting so many more people and
going back out again and I'm like
damn most people just talk [__] behind
their friends backs all [__] day true
and I'm like
damn this is like old high school and
then what did they do on the weekends
just get piss-ass drunk and then the
same thing again and like if you hate
these people what the [__] are you doing
that's just so weird to me yeah yeah I
can't wait for all Steve did we're gonna
talk about someone who shits all over
people all the time and they're but
you're doing this is our CB and she's a
big time tuber cool we'll talk about
tomorrow
let's do it oh whoa okay yeah let's do
it let's do it how are you Colleen uh
what I think or what I think um what do
you think first thing what I think yeah
what do you think um I think nowadays my
ability to listen
is is more of my strength
um because I think before I would speak
more and now in a group like this I've
actually been a little bit more reserved
and been able to kind of like pick up on
certain things and that's actually been
really refreshing
um but I don't know what the Thousand
perspective is you've you've actually
had a problem with like just speaking
like your [__] or no no what I'm saying
is I I usually speak too much like I
usually in the Chatterbox you've got a
directorship yeah I'm usually the one
that's leading the conversation and the
majority of my life in my my day-to-day
life and I think in a group like this in
an environment like this I have my
moments
um but it's nice to just take a backseat
for once but aren't you just overpowered
by a bunch of guys we're overpowered
yeah maybe maybe that too but it is nice
to just [__] you know being around a
bunch of Alphas you know yeah a bunch of
Sigma males yeah like obviously we're
gonna be doing you know what I love
about Steve is that he's such a beta
I love that Steve's such a beta it's
like what it was like a best traits
about him he owns it yeah he owns it you
know like do beta step on their chick's
head
whoa dude I'm really insecure about this
holy [__] he was working his way up to
be beyond the cast of fresh and fit but
you just took that down he'll never be
on it anymore that's
Pity Me of success nowadays that's the
epitome of alpha everything dude show me
the back of your shirt oh dude I'm a
[__] king of crypto what are you
talking about crypto is the crypto king
of beta I don't think so bro if you call
yourself a king is that bad no it's not
that's called Alpha it's called Alpha
energy it's called compromising it's
called exaggerating too to a degree I
think what it's likable about you is
they're very open-minded because uh when
you first came in
like I'm always just scared with like
new energy and then like so I kind of
watch out for that like as we say crazy
[__] kind of like what people's
reactions are and then like you have a
keen sense of like they're [__]
around or they're being sarcastic or
they really believe this or oh I need to
be sensitive and and like in this moment
you know and it's like your ability to
kind of adapt and like understand the
energy of the room versus like some
people I feel like they get like butt
hurt over something or whatever I'm like
yeah there's no feeling of that weird
insecurity or just judgmental thing yeah
and I must touch this here
do you guys find that with a lot of
women that come in
more depends on if they're into comedy
or not I noticed the ones that are
really into comedy like they get it and
the ones that aren't I think they don't
know what we're doing so they don't know
if we're doing sad like they think
they're we're like we're literally
meaning it and it's like no that's just
an act but also with dudes like you can
tell how attached a dude is to their
ideas so for us like there could be
something I'm extremely or any of us are
extremely like he obviously like Nick
who loves Jiu Jitsu right he's trained
he's trained it for [__] 10 years he
does every [__] night if we [__] on
Jiu Jitsu and say how [__] gay it is
he doesn't give a [__] okay he's not
attached to it and then so you can kind
of feel like like when people are really
attached to their [__] you're like dude
you need to [__] chill out and you
kind of don't fit the energy of the room
that's so true but you guys don't think
juice is gay though right we do yeah we
do I thought it was meant to be this is
is this that tire is this is this good
concept it goes back to actually what
BART said right he doesn't take himself
too seriously that's kind of the key to
this room I think yeah none of us really
do yeah we're all just [__] around I
think I think for the most part like I'm
maybe I'll speak for myself on this part
but like I take humor as like a coping
mechanism for anything in my life and if
I don't have humor then life is just
super cynical and it gets really
depressing yeah so I mean I have to have
that you're always good at knowing the
joke though like even outside of here
like you're you're good at knowing it
and playing along without Auto agreeing
which I think a lot of people do as a
method of thinking they get the joke
because they just like you know try to
just be on the same page verbally but
you kind of just get it you know who's
good with that too
um Shannon boudron she used to oh yeah
she's a master like yeah I mean she
might not participate in certain jokes
but she gets it and she understands you
mentioned they mentioned I did she's
like a sex there
loves to [__] loves to suck
that's her tagline yeah see she would
laugh at that yeah Colleen's really good
at just being able to flow with everyone
and kind of like what you mentioned
earlier about just observing and seeing
and then jumping in like you kind of
ride the wave together and it's not like
this you're not trying to control a
narrative and I think a lot of people do
that right they have a they have a
stance of what they really believe in
and then they think we're just gonna
join that journey and we're like no I
don't believe that I mean I also circles
back to what Steve said it's like I
really don't give a [__] yeah like I'm
not trying to prove anything to anybody
like you can think whatever you want
about me like I'm here just having fun
with my friends and conversing and if
you want to pick up on something and
create your own narrative and run with
it it's like when people bring up
politicians to me I'm like I don't
believe in them yeah yeah yeah I don't
care what you think I think I don't
think I don't believe in these people no
like believe me but they're entertaining
so then when we talk about politicians
it sounds like you might be supporting
one or the other but no it's just we're
talking about how entertaining that's
the topic Trump is funny yeah has good
lines yeah Biden is hilarious at
physical comedy
that's a strength yeah exactly yeah he's
incredible he's maybe the greatest
president we've had at physical comedy
ever yeah yeah but do we believe in them
[__] no I never met this person in my
life and now I want RFK you know why
because he cares about Bitcoin AKA pump
my [__] bags I don't give a [__]
pump my [__]
but I do feel like in order to exist in
this room that's the energy that we need
and whenever there's someone that's
smoldering oh I can't believe you just
said that yeah that's I do I do it
creates so much tension in the room I
really love faking that tape though yeah
yeah yeah
that's funny I like acting like what you
said is so appalling like when I do bear
videos Ryan's like
I'm ready to flip the [__] table he
doesn't do he doesn't do it for anything
except for when I do bear videos only
because I always send them to the group
chat for the boys when I'm not around
and I said I send all these bear videos
it's such a Hot Topic guys this is
[__] crazy the Bears are like doing
all kinds of human [__] this is getting
insane and it's like it's like a
Yosemite sham to bugs moment it's like
ooh Steve
I like doing that [__] I think that's
really good but
when Anthony Lee is here
I do get offended by the things that he
says
especially because he could have created
that dance
and how it didn't really happen and a
midgets 35 pounds how funny could it be
yeah you're throwing a [__] around how
much could you throw it like a bowling
ball maybe what about you Ryan what do
you think is uh what you think is
likable about you I think I think
something that I've always thought is
that
I I try to remember a lot of details
about people yeah you're very attentive
very true and then that kind of like I
think that kind of
sort of at least hopefully shows not
paying attention
I think a lot of the time I've noticed
people just get surprised at like why
would you remember that can I say a
criticism yeah sometimes I think uh
that's a different video
because Ryan's too likable we gotta even
it out wow okay constructive
constructive feedback sometimes I think
you remember too much and that's scary
and also too it's like it's like I
better not make this guy mad well he's a
psychopath for good yeah that's what I'm
saying he's too thoughtful sometimes I'm
like how the [__] did you remember that
yeah you know and then I get mad I also
genuinely think it's fun I just like
collecting like that about people at
least behind you
at an ATM he memorized your [__] code
yeah he's a little he's a little
too
no but he did he withdraws your entire
bank account but then he like cashes it
out and then he gives it to you the
duffel bag like 10 months later and he's
like hey he's like see it's all good and
you're like I ruined my life
my life is over yeah I just go oh
am I still likable no I think Ryan has
the
pretty much everybody or make or make
people like feel extremely comfortable
like anybody yeah
um there's like a sense of like
compassion
um or I don't even know if relatability
is it because like there are people who
you wouldn't think would be relatable to
you but you have all walks of life all
all walks of life like [__] you made
friends with big herc looks like a bank
robber I went to jail yeah what the [__]
I wouldn't be friends
that's such a special like skill as a
human being to be able to like naturally
and authentically too you're not faking
it yeah you're not putting it on a front
he is a friend collector yeah Franklin
hey you see how many people came to his
[__] birthday his roller rink
birthday it was like it was a small
militia dude I was gonna make you guys
[__] come to that [__]
yeah that's a that's a human superpower
and it's needed in the world the
ultimate yeah is to bring in a pedophile
and then see if Ryan could still
befriend him and then if that guy's like
dude Ryan makes me feel so welcome
I bet I bet it could happen that's the
ultimate test well you make everyone
feel good all the friends you have at
least all the friends you have at least
one of them is
probably Anthony
if I don't know which one it is it's
probably me
that's the rule
holy [__] well we got to the bottom of
it Steve said it yeah I'm just saying
yeah I have my suspicions why do you
think people like Anthony Lee I did send
Anthony a picture oh I did send Anthony
a video though of Tom Cruise jumping out
of an airplane for Mission Impossible
and I was like
obviously you're gonna think this is
funny and he's he replied not small
enough
and Tom Cruise is five one damn I think
Anthony Lee's like more of a fan of
three guys he didn't even laugh at it
he's not small we're talking about
regular Anthony
I think he's I think he's likable by
default yeah he just has a Charisma yeah
he's got the Riz as everyone says oh I
think he just he just carries a thing
where you're like are we talking about
cool Anthony or regular Anthony regular
Anthony yeah
he's definitely the I think he's he's
pretty pretty likable yeah yeah but also
his I think I think once you really get
to know him it's it's really fun because
he's he's very inappropriate yeah in
like really great ways he's really funny
but then you also find that his immune
system sucks ass yeah and he's always
breaking down all the time I think he's
releasing and he says yes to every gig
that exists so it's like their favorite
car that breaks down [__] day like a
DeLorean I can't even drive it he's like
a DeLorean yeah like he's not here right
now because he's opening he's opened a
car dealership yeah
in Indonesia yeah come on dude I'm gonna
break cool yeah that was pretty cool
it's it's definitely a hard question to
answer for yourself yeah because it
feels so freaking weird and then
everyone has to pile on what they think
but wait he's it's a fun introspective
thing he's performing at a grand opening
at a car dealership in Indonesia wait is
that for real yeah
for Mazda
at a for a car dealership
that is so weird oh yeah by the way
gotta get the word um I I also wanted to
point out just as a side funny thing
about Anthony yeah when you look up
Anthony Lee kinjas and you go to image
search one of the uh top results is
Steve talking about how Anthony did A
Dance that denies 911 ever happened no
no way you [__] made it it's so good
did you get to hear look oh we got there
so that it shows Steve's face made a
mock top of the world above all of
Anthony's success
he had a dance about how 911's not real
Anthony Lee posing going like this not
like the length of Anthony's like career
and his success
hey there's a there's a couple shirts
that I randomly found I thought you guys
would like it
oh [__] dude yeah baby this [__] yeah
baby oh it has bullet shirt I just saw I
just saw him when I was shopping and I
was like oh she's a dumb shirt thank you
so much bro holy [__] let me see this is
Bin Laden and George W
[Laughter]
dude this is way better I feel like this
bit Steve yeah a little bit more I think
this is pretty on brand
the best thing about this is Anthony
Anthony Lee would be like so what
oh
my God